As a boy, I loved cars.
When I turned 18, I lost my best friend to a car accident. Like this.
And then I decided I'd dedicate my life to saving one million people every year.
Now I haven't succeeded so this is just a progress report,...
...but I'm here to tell you a little bit about self - driving cars.
Since, our work has focused on building driving cars that can drive anywhere by themselves,...
...any street in California.
We've driven 140,000 miles.
Our cars have sensors by which they magically can see everything around them...
...and make decisions about every aspect of driving.
It's the perfect driving mechanism.
We've driven in cities, like in San Francisco here.
We've driven from San Francisco to Los Angeles on Highway 1.
We've encountered joggers, busy highways, tollbooths,...
...and this is without a person in the loop, the car just drives itself.
In fact, while we drove 140,000 miles, people didn't even notice.
Mountain roads, day and night,...
...and even crooked Lombard Street in San Francisco.
Now I can't get my friend Harold back to life,...
...but I can do something for all the people who died. Do you know that...
...driving accidents are the number one cause of death for young people?
And do you realize that almost all of those are due to human error...
...and not machine error and can therefore be prevented by machines?
Do you realize that we could change the capacity...
...of highways by a factor of two or three...
...if we didn't rely on human precision on staying in the lane...
...but on robotic precision and therefore drive a little bit closer together...
...on a little bit narrower lanes and do away with all traffic jams on highways?
Do you realize that you, TED users, spend an average of 52 minutes per day in traffic...
...wasting your time on your daily commute?
You could regain this time. This is four billion hours wasted in this country alone.
And it's 2.4 billion gallons of gasoline wasted.
Now I think there's a vision here, a new technology,...
...and I'm really looking forward to a time when...
...generations after us look back at us and say how ridiculous it was...
...that humans were driving cars. Thank you.